[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: The Kotlin
language lets you create apps
in less time, writing less
code, and with fewer errors.
Kotlin is so concise that you
can create a complete class
with one line of code.
In this course, you'll
learn everything
you need to program
in Kotlin, including
how to write
extensions to add more
functionality to any class.
Kotlin is officially supported
for building Android apps,
fully integrates with the
Java language and libraries,
and is included with
intelliJ and Android Studio.
To learn Kotlin, take
the Kotlin Bootcamp
for Programmers
course, developed
by Udacity and Google.
Sign up now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]